my first style inspiration is that all
of the versions you know because you
look at every single different version
you're like oh this today tomorrow this
is 2020 wave
it's like collection of fashion I feel
like every Batman suit is like just
another day in the life that could be
your outfit depending on how hard you're
willing to go for the vision the gray
and the blue suits and the yellow and
stuff like that's dope
Nightwing is awesome with Nightwing is
Robin I call me I I was Nightwing for
Halloween one time and I think that was
my favorite Halloween costume to the
point where I think I'm going to do it
again this year yeah I think Bruce Wayne
is cool too but he's trying to fit in
with everyone so that no one knows he's
mad Batman accessories are just the most
next level like the car the cave the
helicopters the motorcycles
for everything number two I think
Poseidon
this I didn't has influenced me all
types of ways if you look at the
sculptures though has a lot of drapes
just with the drapes and with the
silhouettes you know always when I was
young I always got to me I always knew
that he was one of my fashion icons
inspirations Poseidon has a lot of
chains and jewels he also has a huge
like trident he has a trident it's late
and he you know he's ablaze just my I
would wrap up beside it actually no I
wouldn't I don't like to have like hair
growing out of my face it's so much of
it probably Gator Tyler is a business
mogul and genius
Tyler has always innovated fashion and
taking things that were like not as
popular and made them like SuperDuper
popular I just like always looks
honestly he's just a vibe on every level
I didn't know about so cream until Tyler
you know he's just put everybody on to
so much stuff how this hair for the last
Grammys was awesome and just really want
him to open up a furniture store that's
what I really wanted you know I wanted
to interior directory everyone's house
so that he can just have a store if you
can sculpt by it w vibe Steven Spielberg
I feel like his hats that he wears are
always really good his glasses his
choice of shirts and jackets are really
good too the glasses and the hot is just
he's just did it
I feel like Spielberg really just
defined just certain pieces of fashion
for me in ways that no one else has
my final fashion hero is Picasso he was
just next-level
and his pants always had paint on them
she would always have very like delicate
outfits the colors that he chose were
always very next level it just spoke to
me for some reason amazing just just
like elegance elegance in its finest you
know when I was young I'll always be
like wow
Picasso's really just styling on them
right now when I get older I just want
to style on them like that
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]